now for new information and I have to
qualify this new
information
okay you'll find a tendency
amongst Christians and
Jews to elaborate biblical
stories to elaborate biblical stories
that are actual historical events but as
they reflect on them meditate on them
they start ating on them and then tra
Traditions arise and myth myths develop
so let me repeat I want you to
understand okay understand this everyone
the Bible records actual history these
are historical events but what you'll
find among the Jews and Christians is
that as they reflect on these biblical
stories as they meditate on them they
develop traditions and myths that arise
from their attempt to understand
understand what the Bible says and go
deeper so just because you may have
mythical stories related to actual
historical figures that doesn't mean
these historical events did not happen
it means that these historical events
became
mythologized due to reflection and
meditation by Jews and Christians who
wanted to go deeper and go behind the
surface level of the text are you with
me
there you understand what that means
just because you have myths that arose
based on biblical events doesn't mean
those events are not historical they are
historical they are true history but due
to the Curiosity of Jews and Christians
as they start reflecting on these
stories they try to want to go behind
the surface beyond the surface and try
to come up
with understanding and ideas so then
because of that reflection Traditions
arise and myths develop and I'll give
you an excellent example St Nicholas an
actual fourth Century trinitarian Saint
Who Loved Jesus Christ and was known for
his graciousness and charitability he
was actually at the Council of NAA and
he jacked Aras some traditions say he
slapped him in the face because he
couldn't
handle his blasphemy well St
Nicholas became the EMP
for Santa Claus Santa Claus is based on
St
Nicholas so would you say that St
Nicholas didn't exist because Santa
Claus is a fairy tale no Santa Claus is
a mythologizing of an actual historical
person an actual Saint who loved and
worshiped the Lord Jesus Christ who was
a trinitarian and was known for being
gracious and helping those in need
you better watch out you better not
shout you better not pout I'm telling
you why Santa Claus is coming to Jack
Aras in the
face so you you understand
right Santa Claus is based on St
Nicholas St Nicholas is an actual
historical figure a trinitarian saint
who was at the Council of NAA who jacked
Aras in the face for his blasphemy
because he was being nauy not nice right
who then was in prison but then had a
vision where the Blessed Mother in Jesus
came to him and he was released the next
day so notice what happened an actual
person gives rise to a myth Santa Claus
everyone got
it he sees you when you're sleeping he
sees you when you're
awake I should have made him my Patron
Sint but Jerome's my Patron Sint so you
see how it works
yeah because I've read some accounts
says he slapped him some said he punched
him whatever he did he's a man after my
heart so do you understand the
comparison so I can move on real life
historical events real life historical
characters give rise to myths and fables
and
traditions okay we got it that's why you
even find in the case of Jesus and his
Apostles second third fourth fifth
century
fables about the Child Jesus and the
teenage Jesus and his
exploits unless you are one of these
hypers
Skeptics that doesn't believe Jesus
exists no serious historian or Bonafide
scholar denies historical Jesus
similarly with Adam and Eve Jewish
traditions and fables develop because
with that said
with that said I'm going to now show you
some traditions that developed among the
Jews where you're going to be blown away
how they point to Jesus so let me
explain how God operates you guys got to
listen if you don't listen you're going
to understand this honestly the demons
are manifesting so you don't listen but
by the partly Spirit Focus God in his
love God in his Mercy will condescend to
accomodate Culture by taking even their
myths and using their myths to point to
the truth of Jesus Christ so if there's
a myth about Adam God will then design
the life of Jesus in such a way to be
the actual fulfillment of that myth so
even though that myth didn't happen
people think it happened so God in his
love to do everything he can to bring
them to Christ will then have Jesus live
out that event that is mythological a
myth in the life of Adam but actual in
the life of
Jesus do you understand that because I
can't move on if you didn't get that
point if you don't get that point you
won't understand so once again God and
his love will condescend because Isaiah
57:15 says our God is a humble God a
generous and gracious God who will
humble himself to meet you at your level
to do everything he can to convince you
Jesus is Lord
that means he'll often even use your
myths to bring you to Jesus and you find
this and third W cultures and stories of
evangelists going there and how a myth
that was circulating among the cultures
was designed in such a way that led them
to accept Jesus Christ okay so here
you're going to see God doing that
sending Jesus to actually live out in
the case of Jesus it's not myth it is
actual history living out some of these
mythical stories about Adam and I'll
give you an example in my article I
quote a story that was written by the
Jews called the life of Adam and Eve
there's a Latin version and an Armenian
version of it now let me blow you away
about this story it's in my article
according to this story the life of Adam
and Eve a Jewish Source adopted by
Christians when God created Adam to be
his physical
image Michael brought Adam before God
Adam was animated and God commanded
Michael worship my image and Michael did
so then Michael summoned all the angels
and he said to all the Angels worship
the image of God it says that Satan
refused and in this document Satan is
telling Adam why he hates them if you
read it's right there I quote it here
let me get you the online Link so you
can read online
Satan tells Adam why he hates him so
much he says thee reason why I hate you
is because the day you were created I
was commanded to worship you and here's
what Satan says to him here's the link
where you can read online English
translation of the online version Look
what Satan says and this is where
Muhammad got the story in the Quran
Satan and was commanded with the angels
to worship Adam and refused to do so
where did Muhammad got get the story
from this
Fable yep Tupac
exactly so let me read what Satan tells
him when Michael said
worship Adam because he's the image of
God look what Satan says and it's Satan
narrating the story to
Adam watch here guys let's see if you're
going to catch it because you're going
to see where I'm going with
this having gone forth m
called all the Angels saying worship the
image of the Lord God just as the Lord
God has commanded Michael himself
worshiped first then he called me this
is Satan talking to Adam then Michael
called me and said worship the image of
god
Jehovah now watch this though so then
what does Satan say he
said watch here look at the response now
this is not in the Bible if it happened
I don't know if it's a myth that's okay
because God will work through myths to
bring you to the truth I answered now
this is same telling Adam I told Michael
I do not have it within me to worship
Adam I can't worship Adam when Michael
compelled me to worship I said to him
why do you compel me I will not worship
Him who is lower and posterior to me I
am prior to that creature before he was
made I had already been made he ought to
worship
me you catch it you Adam the image of
God worship me I don't worship you and
because of that and the angels who
agreed with Satan were cast out that's
why Satan hates Adam now watch
here watch what
happens now here's where you're going to
get blown away in the connection with
Jesus Christ and we're going to go into
salvation if you're okay unless you want
me to do that
separately hearing this the other Angels
were under me were unwilling to worship
Him Michael said worship the image of
God if you don't Worship the Lord God
will grow angry with you say right
that's what he said and I said if he
grows angry with me I will place my seat
above the stars of heaven and I will be
like the most high so he got expelled
okay watch what happens when Adam hears
this guess
what it says when Adam hears this guess
what the narration says Adam
went to the Jordan River and fasted for
days as an act of contrition and
penitence to the Jordan River fasted 40
days as a sign of Contrition and
repentance there it is Adam said to Eve
you cannot do as much as I but do as
much as so that you might be saved for I
will do 40 days of fasting fasting where
Adam watch
here watch
here and we're going to tie it in with
Jesus stand in the water of the river
for 37 days so you do 37 days I however
will do 40 days in the water of the
Jordan perhaps the Lord will have mercy
on us okay so watch this here watch the
last
part how many
days okay let's see if you catch it Adam
truly persevered for 40 days standing in
penitence in the waters of the Jordan
let's see if you're making the
connection Adam after he sin fasted 40
days in the Jordan River as a sign of
Contrition with the hopes that God would
forgive
him Satan is commanded to worship Adam
because he's image of God he says no
Adam should worship
me in jubilees 3: 8-9 watch this in
jubilees this is all My article chapter
3: 8-9 it says that when Adam was
created he was only placed in the garden
40 days later and after Adam had
completed 40 days in the land where he
had been created we brought him into the
Garden of Eden now I don't think you're
getting
it Adam was only brought into the garden
40 Days
Later Adam was created an image of God
to be the phical image of the invisible
God and the angels were to worship Adam
because he's God's image Satan said no
he should worship me and he got punished
when Adam sinned he was expelled and
then he spent 40 days in the Jordan
River in Contrition and penitence with
the hope that God would forgive him
Jesus gets baptized in the wilderness
I'm sorry baptized in the Jordan River
then the Holy Spirit comes in him and
fills him and in Luke 3:38 we're told
not only is Adam the image of God he is
the Son of God Luke 3:38 so Jesus the
son of God gets baptized in the Jordan
River the Holy Spirit comes upon him in
him and fills him and he goes in the
wilderness 40 days where Satan now wants
the last Adam to worship him just like
he wanted the first Adam to worship
him all my article you catch
it so according to this myth
Satan wanted the first Adam to worship
him because he thought he was better
than the first Adam because he's older
than him even though God said no you're
going to worship Adam because he's my
image he's the physical image of God
Jesus the last Adam who also is the
image of the invisible God Colossians
1:15 Colossians 115 we are told Jesus is
the image of the invisible God the first
of all creation 2 Corinthians 4:4 we are
told that the glory of God which shines
in the face of Jesus and the gospel
proclaims the glory of Christ who is the
image of God so Jesus like Adam Son of
God Jesus like Adam the image of God
Jesus like Adam spends 40 days Adam in
the River Jordan Jesus in the wilderness
after he comes out of the River Jordan
and Adam
repents for his sin because he failed
and succumbed to Satan but Jesus
overcomes Satan and defeats
him and Adam's only placed in the garden
40 days after his
creation and I'm getting to another
Point connecting with Jesus as the last
Adam who conquers Satan though the first
Adam fail the first Adam
failed the Temptation Of Satan the last
Adam conquered Satan and guess how
Satan tempted Adam with
food eat of the forbidden fruit of the
tree of knowledge and good and evil and
they were not hungry Adam and Eve in
perfect bodies in perfect condition with
plenty of tre to eat from were tempted
by food and succumbed Jesus the last
Adam fasting hungry and thirsty tempted
to turn stones into bread to fail God
and he overcomes
are you making the connections or no All
In My article I'm giving you the link
again I'm just summing it up so you can
make the
connections So Adam
succumbed to the temptation of eating
forbidden food the last Adam though
hungry and thirsty overcame and then not
succumbed to the temptation of turning
stones into bread the first Adam wasn't
hungry he was in a perfect environment
with perfect conditions in a perfect
body and he still failed the test the
test of eating forbidden food Jesus
allas Adam in an imperfect World in a
corrupt World tainted by sin immorality
and demonic infestation hungry and
thirsty and
overcame so let me repeat the connection
Adam Jesus the image of God Adam Jesus
the Son of
God Satan wanted the first Adam to
worship him not he worship the first
Adam and here when he sees the last Adam
he thinks now maybe he can get the last
Adam to worship him because he sees him
in a state of weakness and Frailty and
if we are to worship the first Adam how
much more the last Adam who is God In
the Flesh infinitely greater than the
first Adam who undid the curse of the
the first Adam and destroyed death which
the first Adam brought into the world
ushering in immortality that's why in
Hebrews 1:6 we are told when God brings
his firstborn into the world again he
says let all of God's angels worship Him
Hebrews 1:6 and it's the same Hebrews in
Hebrews 1:3 where we're told that Jesus
is the exact copy imprint the exact
stamp of God's nature are you making the
connections or no
final connection with the first Adam the
last
Adam Adam was dwelling with the beasts
of the field Genesis 2:19
right in that perfect world there was
perfect harmony between Adam and the
Beast of the field but because of sin
that Harmony was destroyed and he was
expelled and there were cherubim barring
him but when Jesus Jesus defeated
Satan Mark
1 Mark 1 when Jesus defeated Satan guess
what happens Mark 111
12-13 watch
here in the wilderness watch here guys
let's see if you make the connection the
first Adam lived with beasts in Perfect
Harmony but because of sin he destroyed
that Harmony and was expelled from the
garden and then cherubim and instead of
serving him barred him the last Adam
when he conquered Mark 1 12-13 look at
this the spirit immediately drove him
out into the Wilderness and he was in
the wilderness 40 days tempted by Satan
and he is with wild beasts and the
angels ministered to him so the last
Adam
undoes the destruction the disruption in
the fellowship and communion with angels
and beasts caused by the first atom
because of the first atom Beast animals
are no longer at peace with humans
animals pray on humans humans pray on
animals and the cherubim barred Adam but
the last Adam because he conquered Satan
brings about
relationship communion and peace between
beasts angels and man and the word there
Angels minister to him comes from the
Greek word to mean to serve and minister
like someone who serves at the table
it's
di where we get the word
Deacon we got it there or
no the first Adam because of sin
destroyed the peace and
communion between men animals and spirit
creatures here the last Adam who
conquered Satan you see both wild beasts
now remember they're wild beasts they're
Untamed beasts that you can't control
unlike the beasts in the garden that
were at peace and harmonious with Adam
here Jesus is seen with wild beasts
meaning he's now tamed them and he's
reconciling animals with humans and
Angels serving
him did everyone get these connections
because I'm done
so what does this
mean as the Jews started reflecting on
historical event of Adam and
Eve they started coming up with
Traditions explanations and myths about
Adam and Eve Adam because he's created
an image of God male and female that's
Genesis 1:26-27 and Genesis 5:
1-2 they ran with it saying well hold on
if Adam the male and female are in the
image of God that means they are called
to physically embody God's qualities
right
physically manifest God's qualities
image God visibly and they're the crown
of creation which means that angels are
subject to them
therefore it must mean that God ordered
angels to worship Adam as his physical
image Bearer and the reason why the
serpent became evil and a cursed must be
because he regretted and resented the
fact that he who's older than Adam would
be commanded to worship Adam instead of
Adam worshiping him see how they're
thinking so from that arose this
tradition this myth and another
tradition Rose which is in jubilees 38
to9 and in the life of Adam and Eve that
Adam was only placed in the garden 40
days after his creation and that after
he sin and succumb to
Temptation he then went to the Jordan
River where he
fasted as an act of conition 40 days so
these stories that are not necessarily
historical even though Adam and Eve and
their expulsion is
historical became widespread and
prevalent amongst the Jews and adopted
by the Christians so God what does he do
he sends the last Adam to then live out
the actual events that happened to the
actual Adam and Eve as well as these my
in order to leave the Jews with no
excuse I'm the one all that you think
happened Adam and Eve I'm undoing
because I'm the real Adam the last Adam
to undo the curse of what Adam and Eve
did see how God is doing
it he's working through their myths to
bring them to the realization of who
Jesus
is and if Adam is worthy of worship how
much more the last Adam when he's
perfect and sinless and Destro
the curse of Adam and Eve and brought in
immortality and he's also God In the
Flesh see how it's working if we got it
I'm done with this part